i'm not quite sure what soccer's plan is
going to be in this position i think i
definitely prefer white just because
black
i'm sorry about that
is that you have your attention please
you have you have my attention
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh well you know it's amazing i know
from experience you have my attention
sir you have all of our attention
everyone
on twitch on youtube facebook i don't
know where you're watching this
but you have our attention
it's gonna be lights out after king
eight yep
all right oh
no i guess of the rook hangings
also there you go oh no she threw that
she's getting rid of the figure she's
throwing that
i'm taking up the place oh greg's great
is greg gonna tie his hair oh
that's actually op she's tying her hair
up greg can't copy that's how you know
it's getting
you've serious to be careful about the
about the queen if black plays b6 this
funny
funny line bishop takes d5 knight takes
d5 knight c6
would trap the queen and uh just
something that occurred to me so
oh god don't tell me this is gonna
happen
oh no i'll know you no no no i have a
bad feeling you know
oh no have this nickname that some
people give me
no no it's not gonna there's no way this
is going to
i'm leaving please take with upon alicia
daniel nostradamus naradichski's right
i'm leaving a few days with the knight
oh no take with the ball
oh no daniel
i would have taken the rook on because
he's going to take b2 with check no he's
not
what is happening here knight e5 just i
can't even do it
he does it though brook takes b2
check and wait what's happening
on e5 he's gonna meet him yeah is white
winning this oh it's winning
yes take it and then wait
what the what just happened
my gosh
e6 pawns so sacrifices may be in the air
later in the game
certainly not the case now and i would
okay but c4 no this is
turning i would say in black's favor no
the yeah this is not
uh this is not right for sure
because that d-pawn c-pawn all loose
normally you want pawn on c3 not c4
number one it guards d4
supports the center number two
checkpoint
one and largest laughs at himself
oh my goodness
and don't play rook b2 because that puts
the king on a stalemate so do not play
oh
i don't like that check check yes nice
nice move
these guys are both playing really well
here yeah they really are
wine intended you gotta go rip the eight
or rookie side c3 just push that pawn
i think
just what a wild position no no what no
they could be a stalemate
oh oh my god rook takes you two it was a
scene
it doesn't work anymore oh what the hell
was that
oh my gosh
wait did you see the evaluation bar it
just went much
lower because it wait what is happening
here
hang on a sec because i think the move
by the way was rook takes e7
yes and then there was queen a6 and
bishop takes d5 so
that's what was missed but look at the
time two seconds there's only plus one
in this game and uh rupees mate ruiz
mate
oh my gosh i've made one on the board
lose on time
oh oh my god he forgot about his clock
too
rugby seven big fella let's go come on
come on we're b7 that works no way to
that works too oh my goodness he's
finding the moves hit him
oh man this is gross king c6 is just
that's that's uh that's a classy clap oh
he stepped out of the way for the checks
i got it yeah i got it
that's a mini one oh my god
what rook va has checked me that he was
setting up the whole thing
now he's dropping upon g tube i'm
shedding tears right now what
i'm crying this is incredible this is
this is i don't even want to say nothing
it's a draw okay nobody lost
all right whatever i mean this is
ridiculous here it happens wow
time scrambles okay you got to remember
guys it's time scrambles
what's going to do with the bishop dc oh
rooksy won't check in the queen
we have repetition he might he might see
bishop b6 but doesn't see rook c1
i think that's what's happening so coach
you gotta go you gotta play in your
opponent's time trouble
yeah yeah knight h6 and bishop v6 rook
c1 check there it is yeah rook c1 is gg
really nice move uh unfortunately it's a
move that greg's probably gonna play
anyway because
oh creeps at me queen f7 made oh my gosh
[Music]
but then i see why is it so good for
black the normal moves that i'm looking
at
they're not don't look that good so then
it must be some ridiculous move that
nobody's gonna play so that's how
it's a process of elimination at this
point but here you have to play bishop
e6
uh you do not put your king in the
corner
[Music]
yes what were you saying about putting
the king in the corner robert would you
be as kind as to finish your sentence
for the 30
000 people we have watching
okay can you choose please feel good
move yes you might be able to play king
three next move too
now you can't blink
[Laughter]
queen h2 queen h2 queen f4
oh my gosh she's so happy that that
didn't happen oh queen it's you're still
happening
wait king c354
okay queen e5 and the rook hangs
well it depends where the king goes now
there's checks and oh the rook just
hangs with chuck
i don't know what to say oh
no robert i feel horrible
i feel just absolutely gutted
that's so heartbreaking to watch
levy actually lost the bullet portion of
that match despite being
much higher rated so here we are what
what nice disrespect
he says get that trump asking the hell
out of here
and did you see levy laugh he's just
like what is this
there's no way that was on purpose was
it that james didn't even he didn't even
blink he was like yep
they cheat yep now that is
a power move knight back to g8 and
looked at that one in the break
did he not notice it either well maybe
sing the
oh 97 queen tigs and then queen d4
oh that's so nice oh he what oh took
back okay your move 24 is good though
for sure okay so what do we have here
opposite bishops i mean
my goodness oh my
gosh danny
oh that's heartbreaking stuff
wow
i think he just noticed he missed it too
yeah he's like what did i do
like what are you doing with me bishop
takes b3 there we go back in the game
rook c2 and what do you do oh
my goodness whoa c is tilting
she dropped the queen no that was me wow
oh my goodness that's not a move on any
and every level guys
on any and every level wow just drop the
whole queen
and everything in between the ice
okay we're going to check the king goes
d3 and drop b2 so g4
and g3 keep it going the bishop covers
g1 that's important to remember but the
bishop does not match a8
i know it made oh okay this is getting
increasingly relevant you know
oh my goodness a7 but white's doing well
here
yeah should just be totally winning
knight takes b5 and then bishop a3
oh my god one time oh lords freaked out
oh my god it's totally winning
oh my gosh lauren's just freaked out
yeah i'm not a big fan of three seconds
left for black i didn't even notice the
time if you take on g5
whoa well either talking about the other
thing but oh wait takes on g6
wait oh the rook's hanging the rook
sings you can't take the knight rook h6
knight takes pawn takes and then you
have h5
oh roxy's h5 is winning it's winning for
what oh he blew the rock is hanging
he left the rook hanging and he doesn't
even react how do you blunder a rook
and just take more of a nibble out of
your sweatshirt and nothing else
who is this guy and levy is about to
even the score he you could sense he
breathed it out he's like this is even
oh wait why do you take the point to the
bishop f5
e3 he's still got a lot of pawns here he
does but he could have taken a bishop
and he took a pawn there
that was a f4 who's better
i have no idea look at these rooks
they're not coordinated very well
oh my gosh two seconds and now that pun
b take
f3 or take the b2 pawn i'm not sure
which is better f3
f3 what is happening here f2 is that the
rook is hanging but rook takes b1 but
then
bishop d4 what i mean i don't know
oh my god black is winning it's gonna be
we gotta go e2 and bishop c3
oh here it comes okay so what now before
bishop c3 oh that's so nice
and then e2 check yeah what a game he
wins
he's down abrupt
oh gosh and levy kind of laughs it off
but uncomfortably so and roberto is just
like what
did i go through i went through eight
games in one
you